Freitag, 13. März 2020.
Das Spital La Carita in Locarno
macht sich bereit,
Schwerpunktspital zu werden
für Corona-Patienten im Tessin.
Die Nicht-COVID kommen hierhin,
die COVID ins Wartezimmer,
dort haben wir
vier Boxen aufgestellt.
Im Wartezimmer gibt es vier Betten.
- Vier Betten für COVID.
COVID und schwere Notfälle,
die nicht beatmet werden müssen.
Der Rest ist Intensivstation.
Hier muss es immer offen sein.
Wenn es stark regnet,
gibt es sonst einen Sturzbach.
Von morgen an kommen die Leute
auf diese Station, v.a. in die 42,
wo die Hebammen waren,
die ist jetzt ein Zweierzimmer.
Bis zur 21 und 22.
Keinen Kontakt
und Schutz vor Tröpfchen.
Im Moment müssen die Masken genügen,
die Überzüge kommen noch.
Die Idee ist,
dass eine ins Zimmer geht,
die andere bleibt draussen.
Wir arbeiten paarweise.
Wir haben genügend Material für
Inhalationen, Sauerstoff, von allem.
Wir sind bereit.
Ist jetzt klar, dass wir die
Röntgenaufnahmen im Zimmer machen?
Genau.
Sauerstoffflaschen
für den Transport?
Unsere.
Wenn sich der Zustand des Patienten
verschlechtert,
entscheidet der Arzt,
ob er auf die Intensivstation kommt.
Dafür haben wir einen Notfallplan.
Es sind alles Patienten,
die isoliert werden müssen.
Wir haben Unterstützung,
bekommen Hilfe,
und wir werden es schon schaffen,
uns zu organisieren.
Jetzt eröffnen sie dann
den vierten Stock,
weil es bei uns praktisch voll ist.
Schon von morgen an kommen
sieben Pflegende am Morgen,
sieben am Nachmittag
und vier in der Nacht.
Ab heute ist die Hauptsache,
dass wir wissen, wo jeder ist,
damit wir ihn finden,
wenn man ihn braucht.
Noch sieben Patienten
in der Chirurgie C.
Dort hat es 58 Plätze,
und wenn noch sieben kommen,
ist es voll.
Dann beginnen wir,
auch den vierten Stock zu füllen.
Die Chirurgie- und Gynäkologie-
stationen werden umgerüstet
für Patienten mit COVID-19.
Sie melden sie uns an.
Die aus dem Moncucco-Spital Lugano
ist vor 45 Min. abgefahren.
Und die aus der privaten Praxis
kommt in den Notfall.
* Beklemmende Klänge *
Passiamo di qua.
Die Patientinnen und Patienten
kommen aus dem ganzen Kanton.
Sie werden nach genauen Anleitungen
begleitet.
Je nach Schweregrad
kommen die Patienten
auf unterschiedliche Stationen.
Diese Frau kommt direkt ins 207.
Dorthin?
- Ja.
Der blauen Linie entlang und danach
rechts, dort sind die Lifte.
Ich will nicht da bleiben,
wo die Schwerkranken sind.
Ich hatte eine Transplantation
und mein Immunsystem ist kaputt.
Also ich will nicht hier bleiben.
Zuerst haben Sie gesagt,
es sei gefährlich für mich,
und ich solle nicht hier bleiben.
Und jetzt bin ich schon
5 Std. hier.
Ich will doch nicht krank werden.
Gehen Sie dort nach hinten!
Ich will hinaus an die Luft.
Dorthin,
dort ist der Abstand genug gross.
Der "Stress", liegt manchmal
eher in der Kommunikation.
Aber wir schaffen es.
Wir sind das gewohnt.
Klar ist jetzt
eine andere Situation,
aber schwierige Unterhaltungen
wie diese hatten wir auch schon.
Wir lernen, damit umzugehen.
Hier in der Notfallstation
sind wir daran,
den Patientenfluss
zu reorganisieren,
damit wir die Patienten
mit Atemproblemen
und/oder dem Verdacht oder
schon einer Diagnose auf Corona
absondern können.
Hier müssen wir vorausdenken
und alles für den schlimmsten Fall
bereitmachen -
und warten, bis es losgeht.
Doch Tatsache ist,
schon in den vergangenen 48 Std.
ist der Rhythmus schneller geworden,
aber im Moment
ist alles "unter Kontrolle".
Wir sind ja auch sonst
oft im Stress.
Das ist nicht aussergewöhnlich
oder selten in unserer Arbeit.
Fieber und Husten, seit Samstag.
* Sie hustet. *
Ich weiss nicht,
wo ich es aufgelesen habe,
weil ich nicht viel unterwegs bin.
Ich bin immer zu Hause.
Sehr wahrscheinlich
werden wir alle
oder ein Teil von uns
daran erkranken.
Wichtig ist,
dass dies abwechselnd geschieht.
Damit einer, der krank wird,
gesund werden und wieder
an die Arbeit zurückkehren kann,
damit dann jemand anderes
krank werden kann.
Leben Sie allein zu Hause?
Nein, d.h.,
ich habe zwei Schwestern,
eine neben und eine über mir.
Und wie geht es denen?
- Die haben im Moment nichts.
Und haben Sie sie in letzter Zeit
getroffen?
Ja.
Sie ist positiv.
Aber es ist auch wichtig zu wissen,
ob sie eine Grippe hat oder nicht,
dann kommt sie
auf eine andere Abteilung.
Jemand mit Grippe kommt nicht
an den gleichen Ort wie jemand,
der COVID-19-positiv ist.
Sonst stecken sie sich
auch noch mit Grippe an.
Aber zwei, die nur COVID haben,
können auch
im gleichen Zimmer liegen.
Ciao. Ce la chiama tra due minuti.
Ein Teil des Personals ist
von auswärts zurückgeholt worden,
aus anderen Funktionen.
Ich z.B. bin als Ausbildnerin tätig.
Andere Kolleginnen
kommen aus der ambulanten Betreuung.
Wir sind alle spezialisiert,
wir haben mit der Zeit
unseren Weg gemacht.
Und jetzt haben sie uns gefragt,
ob wir wiederkommen könnten.
So sind wir zurückgekommen.
Innerhalb von vier Tagen haben sie
zwei neue Stationen eröffnet,
das sagt doch alles.
Innerhalb weniger Tage wurden 45
Pflegende und 16 Ärztinnen und Ärzte
aus anderen Akutspitälern in die In-
tensivstation von Locarno versetzt.
Unsere Schichten dauern 12 Std.
und 45 Min., also fast 13.
Weil es 12 Std. sind,
plus 45 Min. für die Übergabe.
Im Normalfall machen wir das nicht
länger als drei oder vier Tage.
Aber jetzt stehen wir
voll zur Verfügung
und sind praktisch immer hier.
Wenn es nötig ist, geht man halt.
Wer aus dem Ausland kommt, wie ich,
bleibt hier und steht zur Verfügung,
solange es nötig ist.
* Beklemmende Klänge *
Das sage ich immer. Verschieben wir
die Spitze - so ist das.
(Stimme am Telefon)
Aber die Grafik ist von heute.
Die neuen Fälle
nehmen schon jetzt Tag für Tag zu.
Und nach zwölf Tagen
sind es schon mehr als vorausgesagt.
Also die neuen Fälle
nehmen jeden Tag zu,
und schon jetzt sind es mehr als
nach dem schlechtesten Szenario.
Ich glaube,
zwei sind auf der Station gestorben.
Und einem Patienten auf der Inten-
sivstation geht es sehr schlecht.
Alles, was man vorausgesagt hat,
tritt jetzt ein.
Nach einer Woche wissen wir, ob es
ihnen besser geht oder schlechter.
Im Moment,
wie ich schon gestern gesagt habe,
müssen wir warten und beobachten,
was in den nächsten 24 Std.
passiert.
Wir geben Antibiotika,
Antivirus-Medikamente
und beatmen ihn.
Der Zustand ist stabil.
Ihnen geht es gut?
Im Rahmen des Möglichen, klar.
Das glaube ich.
Es tut mir wirklich leid, Signora,
aber jetzt gerade ...
Auf Wiederhören.
Ich komme.
Während ihr ihn vorbereitet,
mache ich bei ihr fertig.
Also Leute. Auf drei geht's los.
Uno, due e tre.
Wenn wir die Patienten
auf den Bauch legen,
geht der Sauerstoff
viel besser ins Blut.
Sie bleiben viele Stunden lang
so liegen, dann drehen wir sie,
weil es sonst
Druckstellen geben könnte.
Und wir sehen auch,
wie sie darauf reagiert haben.
Und dann drehen wir sie wieder.
So machen wir es
mind. sieben oder zehn Tage lang.
Die Pfleger und Ärzte,
und auch alle andern hier,
wir sehen keine Gesichter mehr.
Die Leute haben also
keine Namen und Vornamen mehr.
Es sind einfach Menschen, für die
wir uns einsetzen, um sie zu retten.
Und das verbindet uns alle hier.
Hier war bis vor sechs Jahren
die alte Intensivstation.
Dann diente sie als Tagesklinik,
und jetzt haben wir sie in 24 Std.
wieder
in eine Intensivstation umgewandelt.
* Beklemmende Klänge *
Wir Pflegenden
sind auf solche Sachen vorbereitet,
weil wir seit Langem
mit dem Tod zu tun haben.
Ich bin eine alte Kämpferin
und habe schon viel gesehen. Aber
das jetzt ist etwas völlig anderes.
Es ist wirklich schwierig.
Die Verwandten können nicht kommen,
diese Patienten sind allein.
Stellen Sie sich vor,
wie ihre Verwandten zu Hause
Angst haben
und ihre Liebsten
nicht besuchen können.
Wir versuchen,
ihnen so nah wie möglich zu sein,
als ob sie unsere Verwandten wären.
Aber es ist schon schwierig,
eine ganz andere Situation.
Ich wohne
im italienischen Cannobbio.
Meine beiden Kinder habe ich
bei meinen Eltern untergebracht,
und ich bleibe hier,
bis diese schlimme Zeit vorbei ist
und man mich hier
nicht mehr braucht.
Theoretisch müssten wir
eine halbe Stunde
ausserhalb der Station Pause machen,
aber das schaffen wir gar nicht.
So bleiben wir hier und essen,
was sie uns
aus der Kantine gebracht haben.
Jetzt kommt so viel Arbeit aufs Mal.
Viele Änderungen v.a. Das ganze
Spital ist auf den Kopf gestellt.
All die Weisungen,
die jeden Tag ändern.
Jeden Tag gibt's etwas Neues.
- Jeden Tag kommt neues Personal.
Man muss sich daran gewöhnen
und einfach wissen,
mit wem man gerade arbeitet.
Wir würden gern mehr tun,
aber wir haben keine Zeit.
Diese Patienten sind allein,
wirklich allein.
Und ob es ihnen gut
oder schlecht geht,
sie haben nur uns,
weil niemand anders rein kann.
* Beklemmende Klänge *
Bei mir hat es vor einer Woche
mit hohem Fieber begonnen.
Ich bin dann sofort zum Arzt
gegangen, dort war alles bereit.
Das Röntgen ging gut,
aber ich hatte erhöhte Blutwerte.
Und dann wurden
weitere Untersuchungen gemacht,
weil mein Immunsystem
unterdrückt ist.
Sie haben dann einen Virusabstrich
gemacht,
einen normalen und einen auf Corona.
Wenn man dann hört, dass der normale
Virusabstrich in Ordnung ist,
und sie auf die Resultate
des Corona-Abstrichs warten,
hört man auf, zu leben.
Am Montag bekam ich dann
die Bestätigung.
Dann geht einem
so viel durch den Kopf,
v.a.
wenn man Gesundheitsprobleme hat.
Nach zwei Tagen
ist es schlimmer geworden.
Ich konnte dann nicht mehr
gut atmen und rief die Ambulanz.
Mitten in der Nacht haben sie mich
hierher nach Locarno gebracht.
Jetzt bin ich auf der Intensiv-
station und erhalte Sauerstoff.
Gestern haben sie an mir
eine neue Behandlung getestet,
die in den nächsten 24-48 Std.
wirken
und diese Lungenentzündung
etwas stoppen sollte.
Ich hoffe, dass ich es schaffe,
weil es eine furchtbare Zeit ist.
Die, die es schaffen, haben Glück,
oder die,
die nur wenige Symptome haben.
Aber wir sind nicht alle gleich.
* Stimmengewirr *
Wir haben keine Gegensprechanlage,
wir können nicht
anders kommunizieren.
Seit ein paar Tagen
geht es mir besser.
Das Fieber ist gesunken,
und seit heute Morgen
habe ich wieder Appetit. Zehn Tage
lang habe ich nichts gegessen.
Jetzt bin ich wieder zuversichtlich,
weil ich sehe, dass es besser geht.
Als sie das Virus entdeckt haben ...
Eines Morgens bin ich aufgewacht.
Schon am Abend
hatte ich etwas Fieber -
und am Morgen waren es dann 38,5 °C.
Da ich eine Transplantation hatte,
rief ich im Spital Moncucco
meine Ärztin an.
Die sagte, ich solle schnell
herkommen für einen Abstrich,
damit wir sofort Ruhe hätten.
Also ging ich - und bin nicht mehr
nach Hause zurückgekehrt.
Ich bin zum Notfall gegangen,
weil ich nicht wusste, was los war.
Ich war ohnmächtig geworden.
Dann haben sie mich zur Sicherheit
gründlich untersucht,
ich war ohnmächtig und hatte wahr-
scheinlich einen Blutdruckabfall.
Sie haben also alles kontrolliert
und auch einen Test
auf Coronavirus und Grippe gemacht.
Der Grippetest war negativ, aber der
auf das Coronavirus dann positiv.
Da ich zu einer Risikogruppe gehöre,
weil ich Asthma habe,
haben die Ärzte mich zur Sicherheit
für ein paar Tage hier behalten,
um zu sehen,
wie sich die Krankheit entwickelt.
Die ersten Tage sind sehr wichtig.
Wenn sich die Situation in den
ersten Tagen nicht verschlechtert,
kann man wieder gesund werden.
Damit der Betrieb
nicht zusammenbricht,
muss andauernd neu geplant werden.
Tag für Tag kommen neue Fälle dazu,
mehr als erwartet.
Das Spital
hat 210 Betten bereitgestellt.
180 normale
und 30 in der Intensivpflege.
Aber das sind bereits zu wenig.
Wir stellen hier
vier provisorische Boxen auf
für schwerkranke Patienten,
die in den Notfall kommen.
So wollen wir so gut wie möglich
die andern entlasten,
damit mehr Platz bleibt
für die Intensivtherapie.
Sie haben eine Infusion gelegt
und machen jetzt die Abstriche.
Dann mache ich eine Blutgasmessung.
Heute leeren wir praktisch
den ganzen dritten Stock.
Da bleiben bis Mittwoch
höchstens sechs Patienten.
Am Donnerstag
leeren wir die Geriatrie.
Die haben wir noch ausgelassen -
jetzt werden dort
nochmals 14 Betten frei.
Jetzt sind die Physiotherapeuten
anderer Spitäler gekommen,
um uns zu helfen.
Weisst du,
wie viele Geräte wir haben?
Wir möchten wissen, wie viele
für die Patienten verfügbar sind.
* Leise Gespräche *
Wenn man diese Dinge aus China
hört, denkt man immer,
man sei besser als die andern,
und bei uns stürben sie nicht.
Aber jetzt
müssen wir uns eingestehen,
dass die Chinesen
nicht schlechter sind als wir.
Sie sind genauso gut wie wir, und
wir sind genauso machtlos wie sie.
Jetzt sterben die Leute auch hier.
Wenn es so weitergeht,
wird mit unseren 14 Bettenplätzen
in der Lungenstation
die ganze Kapazität
in drei Tagen ausgeschöpft sein.
Denn jetzt kommen noch
zwölf Patienten von ausserhalb.
Wissen wir, wie viele
aus dem Sottoceneri sind?
Denn ab Mittag müssen sie
ins Moncucco-Spital nach Lugano.
Ab heute Mittag kann Moncucco
die Corona-Patienten aufnehmen.
Alle Patienten aus dem Sottoceneri
müssen ins Moncucco verlegt werden.
Auch die Intensivfälle?
- Ja, alle.
Das verlangsamt die Eintritte
und verschafft uns mehr Platz.
Das einzige Gefühl, das ich habe,
ist, dass wir zu langsam waren,
zu wenig tüchtig und zu wenig fähig.
Das ist das einzige.
Aber Sie tun Ihr Möglichstes?
Das sehen wir dann im Juni.
Im Juni ziehen wir Bilanz.
Dann sehen wir,
ob wir fähig waren oder nicht.